GONNA CALL THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE THAT'S
A ORDER- I KNOW WE HAVE THE
AUTHOR HERE AND I WANNA BE
SENSITIVE EVERYONE'S TIME AND SO
WE'RE GONNA AT A START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE AND THEN- WILL
PROCEED- WITH AS THAT AND THEN-
HERE'S SOME BILLS. SO THAT WE
CAN BE A PERSON WITH A ONE TIME
TO WONDER WHAT EVERYONE WELCOME
EVERYONE BACK AND WHICH ARE WHAT
HAPPY NEW YEAR. DUE TO ONGOING
COVERT PARTICLES I AM PROVIDING
THE FOLLOWING INFORMATION THE
HEARING ROOM IS OPEN FOR
ATTENDANCE AT THIS HEARING BUT
THERE ARE SPACE AND SEATING
LIMITATIONS FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC AND THE PRESS SO WE CAN
ENSURE EVERYONE MAINTAINS SIX
FEET OF SOCIAL DISTANCE. ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC ATTENDING A
HEARING WILL NEED TO WEAR A MASK
AT ALL TIMES ON THE BUILDING WE
ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE
BEEN TESTIMONY BY VISITING THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. PLEASE NOTE
THAT ANY WRITTEN TESTIMONY
SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE IS
CONSIDERED A PUBLIC COMMENT AND
MAYBE READ INTO THE RECORD
REPRINTED. EVERYONE IS
ENCOURAGED TO WATCH THE HEARING
FROM ITS LIVE STREAM ON THE
ASSEMBLY WEBSITE YOU CAN TESTIFY
IN PERSON IN THE HEARING ROOM OR
USING OUR TELEPHONE SERVICE EACH
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC WILL HAVE
TWO MINUTES TO COMMENT STARTING
WITH THOSE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
FOR HERE IN THE ROOM. TO USE OUR
- CELLPHONE SERVICE THAT. THE
NUMBER TO. IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. AGAIN THAT'S EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS ONE THREE. ONE FIVE. FORTY
TWO OH TWO. AGAIN THAT'S ONE
THREE ONE FIVE. FORTY TWO OH
TWO. FOUR WITNESSES CALLING INTO
THE PHONE LINE. WE PLACE IN THE
QUEUE AND SO YOU OPPORTUNITY
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. PLEASE MUTE YOUR DEVICE
TO REDUCE SOUND DISTORTIONS.
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WE BLENDED ON
THE PHONE LINE. PLEASE BE BRIEF
AND LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION.
IF YOU HAVE ANY PROBLEMS. WITH
THE MODERATOR PHONE SERVICE. YOU
CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE AT NINE
ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE. TWO
ZERO NINE THREE. AND OUR STAFF
WILL PROVIDE HELP. FINALLY THE
ASSEMBLY HAS EXPERIENCED A
NUMBER OF DISRUPTIONS THE
COMEDIAN FOR PROCEEDINGS IN
EFFECT PAST FEW YEARS. CONDUCT
THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR
OTHERWISE IMPEDE THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF THE HEARING IS
PROHIBITED. CONDUCT MOMENT MAY
INCLUDE. REMOVING A MASTER IF
USING TO PUT IT ON. A PUT BACK
ON TALKING OR MAKING LOUD NOISES
IN THE AUDIENCE I DURING LOUD
THREATENING OR ABUSIVE LANGUAGE.
SPEAKING LONGER THAN THE TIME
ALLOTTED. EXTENDED EXTENDED
DISCUSSION OF MATTERS NOT
RELATED TO THE SUBJECT OF THE
HEARING OR BILL. IN OTHER
DECEPTIVE ACTS. TO ADDRESS ANY.
DISRUPTIVE CONDUCT I WILL TAKE
THE FOLLOWING STEPS. SORRY FOR
THE LONG SCRIPT EVERY. OF EVERY
F. IN INDIVIDUAL DISRUPTS OUR
HEARING PROCESS I WOULD DIRECT
pTHEM TO STOP. AND WARNED THEM
THAT CONTINUED DISRUPTIONS MAY
RESULT IN THE- REMOVAL FROM THE
CAPITOL BUILDING I WILL ALSO
DOCUMENT ON THE RECORD. THE
INDIVIDUAL INVOLVED IN THE
NATURE OF THE DECEPTIVE CONDUCT
I MAY TEMPORARILY RECESSED THE
HEARING. AT THE CONDUCT IS NOT
STOP. I WILL REQUEST THE
ASSISTANCE OF THE SERGEANTS AND
ESCORTING THE INDIVIDUAL FROM
THE CAPITOL BUILDING. I'D
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
COOPERATION WITH THAT WE WILL
BEGIN OUR HEARING. I KNOW THAT
WE ARE STILL WAITING FOR MORE
MEMBERS TO SHOW UP- SO I HAVE
BEEN SPEAKING WITH- SHARE
FRIEDMAN ABOUT THE MEMORIAL
HIGHWAY NAMING PROCESS I WANT
OUTLINED THAT REAL BRIEFLY FOR
ON BEHALF. OF YOUR FRIEDMAN. AS
OF TWENTY TWENTY. APPROXIMATELY
HUNDRED THOUSAND FREEWAYS
HIGHWAYS ROADS BRIDGES TUNNELS
AND OTHER STRUCTURES HAVE BEEN
NAMED TO THE HIGHWAY RENAMING.
THE HIGHWAY NAMING A RESOLUTION
PROCESS. THIS COMMITTEE PROCESS
TWENTY ONE HIGHWAY NAMING
RESOLUTIONS LAST YEAR WE HAVE
ONE IN TODAY'S HEARING. IT IS
THE INTENT OF THE CHAIR. OF THE
ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE LOOK AT JEFFREY MEANT
TO USE THE ROOM WHILE HAVING A
PROCESS TO HONOR DECEASED.
CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE MADE
SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC SERVICE
CONTRIBUTIONS AND ALSO REFLECT
THE DIVERSITY OF OUR STATE. AND
AN EFFORT TO BETTER REPRESENT
THE DIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. OF
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC SERVANTS IN
THE CURRENT HIGHWAY RENAMING
PROCESS THIS YEAR WILL BE
WORKING TO REFORM THE PROCESS TO
ENSURE IT MEMORIALIZES AND
CELEBRATES. FALLING CALIFORNIANS
EQUITY. EQUITABLY WE WILL BE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH OUR
DEMOCRATIC AND REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES THE SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE. TO
CALTRANS THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL AND OTHER INTERESTED
PARTIES IN THE UPCOMING YEAR AND
WILL KEEP THE COMMITTEE UPDATED
ON OUR PROGRESS. IN STILL WE
HAVE A NEW PROCESS. BILL HERE
AND IMPROVE PROPOSED HIGHWAY.
NAY MAKES- IT WE DON'T HAVE
QUORUM SO WE'LL ON. UNDERSTAND
AB TWO NINETY FOUR. IF YOU'RE
READY WE WILL PROCEED WITH YOUR
BILL AND SUBCOMMITTEE AS AS
SUBCOMMITTEE. THANK. IF YOU
MEMBERS TO DO THE REVERSE OF
THAT WELL. ABSOLUTELY EIGHTY TWO
EIGHTY SEVEN WOULD PROVIDE
CONSUMERS OF FAIR AND SIMPLE
PROCESS TO CHALLENGE EXISTS OF
TOWING AND STORAGE FEES
HIGHLIGHTED SOME CASES GOOD GOOD
WELL WELL BE OVER A THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND CURRENTLY THERE'S NO
DISPUTE RESOLUTION PROCESS AT
THE BUREAU OF AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR-
THAT REFUNDS CONSUMERS RECESSES
STORAGE FEES LEAVING CONSUMERS
WITH NO OPTION. OTHER THAN TO GO
TO COURT AND THIS WOULD CREATE A
VEHICLE TOW STORAGE BOARD THAT
WE RESOLVE DISPUTES BETWEEN TELL
COMPANIES AND THE VEHICLE OWNERS
AND THAT'S WHAT WE HOPE TO DO
THIS BILL AND I RESPECTFULLY
WOULD ASK WHEN I'VE OPEN THIS
COMMITTEE- CONVENES. I THANK YOU
MR SANTIAGO- DO YOU HAVE ANY-
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. ASSEMBLY
MADE IT WE DO HAVE TWO WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT- YES I'M
INTEROPERABLE WOULD YOU PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR. THE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF. THIS
BILL. I BELIEVE IT'S A- MISTER
B. KIRK- BLACKBURN FROM THAT-
CALIFORNIA- TOW TRUCK
ASSOCIATION YEAH ANSWERING
TAYLOR FROM THE- FROM A PERSONAL
INSURANCE FEDERATION CALIFORNIA
OKAY WE'LL GO WITH THE- THE
CHURCH THE CATHOLIC CHURCH
ASSOCIATION FIRST YOU'LL MEET-
YOU MAY PROCEED. GOOD AFTERNOON
BY CHEN MEMBERS THIS IS KIRK
BLACK ARAMBULA DEVOTED ADVOCATE
CALLING ON BEHALF THE COMPANY
TOOK A CONCLUSION A SPONSOR OF
EIGHTY TO NINETY FOUR- INITIAL
DEPLOYMENT THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SANTIAGO FOR OFFERING THAT
SUPPORT BILL AS WELL AS CHAIR
pSTAFFER. FOR PROVIDING. US WITH
EXCELLENT FEEDBACK ANALYSIS. I
THINK IT IS SEVEN UP SPONSOR DUE
TO NON FOUR AND ORDER TO DRIVE
LEARNED OVERSIGHT CALIFORNIA THE
LAST OF A STATE WIDE AND- LEGO.
THE TOWING INDUSTRY. WELL THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF CONSUMER
PROTECTION PROVIDE UNDER CURRENT
LAW THERE'S A LACK OF
ENFORCEMENT TO PREVENT BAD
ACTORS WITH INDUSTRY FROM
CIRCUMVENTING THE FOUGHT.
FURTHER VEHICLE OWNERS ARE
OFTENTIMES WHAT CONFUSED AND
WITHOUT ANY RECOURSE THAT THEY
BELIEVE THEY. WERE OVERCHARGED
WHEN THE VEHICLE WAS TOWED. AB
TWO NINETY FOUR RECTIFY
OVERSIGHT BY NINETY AND NINE.
BOARD UNDER. REPAIRS NAME THE
VEHICLE TOW AND STORAGE BOARD.
EVERY BUSINESS THAT OPERATES A
TOW TRUCK OR CHARGES FOR THE
STORAGE OF THE TOKYO CLINT IN
CALIFORNIA WOULD NEED TO APPLY
FOR A VEHICLE TOWING STORAGE
PERMIT FROM THE BOARD. AND THE
BOARD WOULD HAVE THE AUTHORITY
TO SUSPEND THIS PAYMENT COMPARED
VIOLATIONS OF LAW. AS A
CONDITION OF OBTAINING THE
PERMIT BUSINESSES WE NEED TO
LISTEN AND A HOST OF INFORMATION
ABOARD COULDN'T COME COMPANY
CONTACT INFORMATION. AND
AUTHORIZED TOWING STORAGE RANGE
ALL OF WHICH WILL BE POSTED ON
THE BOARD'S WEBSITE SO CONSUMERS
CAN EASILY ACCESS. AND USE OF
INFORMATION. FURTHER IN ORDER
TO. OVER BILL IN THE AND I A
PRETTY QUICK. FOR DISPUTE
RESOLUTION UP ON THE BOARD WHERE
BANKS. HIS COVER ANYTHING OR ANY
. PAY TO TOWING COMPANY PLUS
TIME. THIS PROCESS WE THAT
TEETERS LOS REQUIRE COMPANIES TO
BUY BUT IT PROVED A POTENT
GREAT. WEALTH WHICH WAS AN
APARTMENT AND LEFT ABILITY TO
TAP INTO LEGALLY TELL DISCORDANT
STATE. OVERALL WE BELIEVE THIS
BILL IS A CRITICAL STEP TOWARD
CURBING THE- OF POWER. BY THE
TELLING THE STORY AND JUST.
THANK YOU. BEFORE WE PROCEED TO
THE NEXT ONE AS WELL ESTABLISHED
QUORUM. AMEND SECTOR WE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE FARM CARE.
BERMAN CUNNINGHAM DALY HERE
DAVIES HERE DAYS HERE GIPSON.
KALRA YOUR COMPANY HERE WE HEAR
WE HERE MEDINA. NAZARIAN
PRESIDENT WHEN O'DONNELL. DONALD
WARD. WICKS HERE. WE HAVE A
QUORUM MISTER CHECK IF ANOTHER
WE REQUIRE MAKE A MOTION TO MOVE
YES MOTIONS ARE SECOND. HELLO
MOTION A SECOND I'M GOING TO THE
NEXT- WITH US IN SUPPORT OF
PERSONAL INSURANCE FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA. YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS I'M SORRY
TAYLOR HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
PERSONAL INSURANCE FEDERATION
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
NINETY FOUR WHICH IS THE LATEST
ON A DECADES LONG EFFORT BY THE
LEGISLATURE TO BETTER PROTECT
CONSUMERS FROM ABUSES AN
EXORBITANT CHARGES IN THE TOWING
AND AUTO REPAIR INDUSTRIES. NOT
SURPRISINGLY THE TELL BUSINESS
IN CALIFORNIA IS LARGELY
UNREGULATED. AND THERE'S NO
DATABASE OF TOVIA BECAUSE
OPERATING CALIFORNIA. THAT MAKES
IT DIFFICULT IDENTIFIED THAT
ACTORS. AND TAKE ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS WHEN APPROPRIATE. SO WE
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
ANCHORMEN TO CALIFORNIA TORTURE
ASSOCIATION FOR COMING FORWARD
WITH A PROPOSAL. TO PUT SOME
REGULATORY ACCOUNTABILITY AROUND
THE TOWING INDUSTRY TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS AND READ OUT THE BAD
APPLES. IN ADDITION TO PROVIDING
OVERSIGHT FOR TOWERS SO ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT COMPONENTS OF
THIS BILL ADDRESSES THE
EXCESSIVE STORAGE REACHED CHARGE
BY OUR REPAIR DEALERS. WHILE
MOST AUTO BODY REPAIR SHOPS ARE
RESPONSIBLE. WE'RE STILL SEEING
TOO MANY THAT ARE TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF CONSUMERS AND
CHARGING EXCESSIVE RATES THE
COST INSURANCE POLICY HOLDERS
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
AND COMPACT WITH A CYCLE OF
POVERTY FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS WHO CANNOT AFFORD
TO PAY THE STORAGE BILLS. I'M
NOT LOSE THEIR CARS AND
SOMETIMES THEIR LIVELIHOOD. NOW
THE OPPOSITION ARGUES THAT THE
CURRENT SYSTEM IS WORKING FINE
TO PROTECT CONSUMERS. BUT OUR
RESEARCH INDICATES THAT'S NOT
THE CASE. WE STILL FIND IT'S
COMMON FOR AUTO REPAIR DEALERS
TO CHARGE STORAGE THE VETERAN
ACCESS TO TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS A
DAY. SOMETIMES IN EXCESS OF A
THOUSAND DOLLARS TODAY. AND BY
COMPARISON TO STORAGE RATE PAID
BY C. H. P. AND I COST CITY LIKE
SANFRANCISCO. IS ONLY NINETY
THREE DOLLARS PER DAY. SO
CURRENTLY THERE'S NO REGULATOR
THAT HAS A STORY TO DEFINE
REASONABLE STORAGE RATES. OR
REQUIRE AN UNSCRUPULOUS BUSINESS
TO REPAIR CONSUMER EXCESSIVE
CHARGES. AS NOTED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THE ONLY
REMEDY FOR CONSUMERS TO BRING A
LAWSUIT AGAINST THE TOWING
STORAGE FACILITY FOR DAMAGES.
AND THAT'S NOT A PRACTICAL
REMEDY FOR MOST PEOPLE. SO
INCLUDING EIGHTY TWO NINETY FOUR
PROVIDE REGULATORY
ACCOUNTABILITY LACKING IN THE
TOWING INDUSTRY. AND ESTABLISH A
FAIR RESPONSIBLE STORAGE RATE
BENCHMARK THAT IS BASED ON
REGIONAL RATES NEGOTIATED BY THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL. AND
WEBER DRIVE OUT THANK YOU. I
VERY MUCH- WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
WHAT IS OPPOSITION I DON'T
BELIEVE WE HAVE ANY LISTED BUT I
WILL. GO TO THE PHONES TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE FROM THE
AUTOMOTIVE SERVICE COUNCIL TO
CALIFORNIA. WITH THE CALIFORNIA
AUTOBODY ASSOCIATION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA AUTOMOTIVE BUSINESS
COALITION- IF THEY'RE ON THE
LINE TO SPEAK. YES THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON JACK MILLER
DONALD ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AUTOBODY ASSOCIATION
THE AUTOMOTIVE SERVICE COUNCIL
CALIFORNIA. THE CALIFORNIA
AUTOMOTIVE BUSINESS- COALITION
WILL CODES UNLESS THE BILL'S
AMENDED. THE BILL IS NOT
NECESSARY WITH. WITH REGARD TO
AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR DEALER'S
AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR DEALER'S ON
THE BUSINESS OF ABANDONED CARS
AND ARE REGULATED. BY THE BUREAU
OF AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR THE P. A.
ART INCLUDING ANY STORAGE FEES
THEY MAY CHARGE. THE TOWING
INDUSTRY IS NOT REGULATED BY THE
B. R. WE CAN UNDERSTAND. THE
INTENTION OF THE BILL THE TOWING
INDUSTRY AND AUTO REPAIR
INDUSTRY ARE COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT BUSINESSES- QUITE
COMPARING APPLES WITH ORANGES.
THE BA ARE FOCUSED SEIZE
APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND. AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR
DEALER'S IN THE STATE. THE B. A.
R. THE BUREAU OF AUTOMOTIVE
REPAIR WE RECEIVED APPROXIMATELY
FIFTEEN THOUSAND COMPLAINTS.
EACH YEAR OUT OF THE FIFTEEN
THOUSAND COMPLAINTS. ONLY SIXTY
ARE RELATED TO STORAGE. EVEN
THOUGH THE NUMBER IS VERY LOW
THE B. R. TREAT STORAGE
COMPLAINT SERIOUSLY INVESTIGATE
THEY MEDIATE AND HAVE TAKEN
DISCIPLINARY ACTION. AGAINST
AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR DEALER'S COST
RELATED STRATEGIES. EIGHTY FOUR
SEVENTY ONE THAT JUST PASSED
THIS LAST YEAR AND TOOK EFFECT
JANUARY FIRST. STRENGTHENED AND
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL AUTHORITY TO
THE BA ARE OVER AUTO REPAIR
SHOPS WITH REGARDS. IN FACT
DURING THE PROCESS
PROMULGATING REGULATIONS STORED
REGULATION AND HE JUST HELD A
WORKSHOP. IN OCTOBER. THE BILL
THE NECESSARY IT'S DUPLICATIVE
THERE'S NO NEED TO CREATE
ANOTHER REGULATORY BOARD TO
OVERSEE AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR
DEALER'S. WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTED THE BILL BE AMENDED.
GOOD SCHOOL GOOD AUTOMOTIVE
REPAIR DEALER'S THAT DON'T HAVE
TOW TRUCKS AND INSTEAD. WORK
WITH THE BA ARE DOING PROVEN
STRENGTH IN THE STORAGE ISSUES
THROUGH THE PENDING REGULATORY
PROCESS. WE THINK THIS IS A
BETTER APPROACH. ALSO THE-
PROHIBITS AUTUMN WOULD DEALER
CHARGING STATE IN MOSCOW RIGHT.
THE CURRENT LAW WHICH WAS A STAB
WITH THE STATUS DE WHO REGIONAL
WHERE. WAS CREATED YEARS AGO IN
A- SO. SANTIAGO BILL A TWO THREE
NINETY TWO THANK YOU THE COMPANY
. ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING
THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL
NEGOTIATED THE STORE. TWENTY I
DON'T THINK IT'S IN TWO MINUTES%
SO YOU CAN WRAP UP. THANK YOU
THERE'S REALLY NO NEED DISC-
DESCRIBE THE STORY'S GREAT
DEFINITION- WE THINK THEY OPEN
THE WORKING AS INTENDED- WE
REQUEST- THAT CURRENT LAW
PROVIDING FOR AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR
DEALER'S TO CHARGE THEIR REPO
RATES NOT BE ELIMINATED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I THANK YOU- WILL
NOW MOVE THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY- I
BELIEVE WE HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL
HERE IN THE IN THE ROOM SO-
ANYONE WHO WANTS TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. PLEASE
COME AND COME FORWARD- TO SICHER
OPPOSITION. SIR YOU A PARTICULAR
SPEAKER MY NAME IS JOE COLLINS I
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION LICENSE
REPOSSESSIONS. I GOT SO MUCH
STUFF HERE IT'S GONNA BE QUICK
FIRST THE BODY SHOPS ARE CORRECT
THEY DON'T HAVE TO- TRUCKS THEY
HIRE THE PREDATORY TOWERS WHO
TOLD THE CARS TO THE TOW YARD.
I'M FELT RECEIVE HERE SIX
HUNDRED EIGHTY DOLLARS FOR ONE
TELL. THE BODY SHOPS CHARGE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS HOW IT
WORKS IS THEY HIRE PEOPLE WHO
WAIT IN IN GAS STATIONS AT NIGHT
TIME. THEY RESPOND BASED OFF OF
A RADIO CALL THE HERE ON THE
SCANNER THEY GO PICK UP THE CAR
THEY TOLD AWAY AND THAT PERSON
THE CONSUMER NEVER SEES THAT CAR
AGAIN. NEVER UNLESS SOMEBODY
PAYS FOR IT THE PERSON WHO PICKS
THE CAR UP DOES NOT WORK FOR THE
BODY SHOP HE'S JUST A GUY WITH A
TOW TRUCK THAT HIM AND SIX OTHER
GUYS HAVE A TOW YARD SOMEWHERE
SO YOU DON'T KNOW WHERE THE CARS
AT. PUBLIC HEALTH RECEIPT IT HAS
NO ADDRESS WHERE THEY LOCATED
AND NOBODY ANSWERS THE PHONE
THAT'S HOW YOU LOSE YOUR CAR
WHEN YOU'RE CONSUMER SO WITH ALL
THIS RESPECT TO THE BODY SHOP TO
REPAIR FACILITIES THEY HAVE AN
ISSUE WITH THAT. THE TOWERS ON
THE OTHER HAND BUT TRYING TO
MONOPOLIZE THE TOWING INDUSTRY
THE WAY THEY'RE DOING THAT IS
ENCOMPASSING EVERYBODY INTO A
PERMIT- PROCESS. IN WHICH
SOMEONE LIKE US THE RE
POSSESSORS. WE HAVE TO FOLLOW
THE FAIR DEBT COLLECTION
PRACTICES THAT THE COLLATERAL
COVER YET. THE GRAMM LEACH
BLILEY ACT WE HAVE TO HAVE
EVERYTHING. OUR EYES DARTED NO
TEASE CROSSED. WHAT THEY WANT TO
DO IS THEY WANT TO GET A HOLD OF
OUR TRUCKS BECAUSE THE PERSON
WHO COMPLAINS ABOUT TOW YARD. OR
THE REPOSSESSIONS WHEN WE PICK
UP THE CARS. I HAVE THE RECEIPTS
TO- I HAVE NOT RECEIVED FROM THE
PERSON WHO DOES THE TRAINING FOR
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. HE CHARGES
A REGULATORY FEE WHICH IS
ILLEGAL. THE TOWING. INDUSTRY
THE CALIFORNIA TOW TRUCK
ASSOCIATION. ONLY WANTS TO
REGULATE THE TOWING IN THE
STORAGE OF THE VEHICLE THAT'S
NOT WHERE THE CONSUMERS ARE
CHEATED THEIR CHEATED ON THE
ANCILLARY FEES BILLION FEES.
ADMIN FEES THE REGULATORY FEES
WHICH ARE ALL ILLEGAL. THIS
BOARD WOULD NOT HEAR THAT
COMPLAINT IF YOU WANT TO
COMPLAIN TO THE BOARD YOU HAVE
TO PAY FIRST SIR AYE YOU
VICTIMIZED BY YOU WANT TO
CLARIFY WHAT IS YOUR POSITION ON
THIS BILL WE OPPOSE OKAY. SO
IMMATURE YOU HAVE TO PAY TO GET
YOUR CAR OUT BEFORE YOU CAN
COMPLAIN. THAT IF YOU DON'T HAVE
THE MONEY BECAUSE THEY'RE
CHARGING YOU EXCESSIVE FEES.
THEN YOU LOSE YOUR CAR. SO WE
OPPOSE THAT WE OPPOSE EVERYTHING
ABOUT THIS BILL IS COMPLETELY
WRONG THIS IS A WOLF IN SHEEP'S
CLOTHING. I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS AND HELLO BLOOD
YOUR TIME HAS BEEN ALLOTTED BUT
OR DOES RUN OUT BUT A FOR THIS
PUBLIC COMMENT THAT HE WOULD
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO THE
COMMITTEE WILL. SO TO MAKE SURE
THE MEMBERS GET IT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
SEEING NO ONE ELSE IN THE-
HEARING ROOM ONE NOW MOVES TO
THE PHONES. TO HEAR A TESTIMONY-
EITHER IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL. THANK YOU LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO DOWN
AT T. OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER OFFLINE QUICKLY IN A
PLACE YOU BACK IN THE QUEUE. SO
AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TWO
SIX PRESS OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT
AT THIS TIME. AND WE WILL GO TO-
LINE FIFTY SIX YOU ARE OPEN. HOW
DID YOU HEAR ABOUT ROBINSON ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA.
DISTRIBUTION IS CONTROLLED ON
THE STRICTLY. AND AGAIN PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO- A PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THIS TIME ONE MOMENT
. IF YOU DO GET ONE ZERO AGAIN
IT'LL TAKE YOURSELF ON A QUEUE
SO. WE'LL GO TO LINE FORTY FIVE. FORTY FIVE YOUR OPEN PLEASE ON
YOU- THANKS FOR HAVING ME- MY
NAME IS STANDARD QUESTIONS I'M
CALLING FROM CALPERS CLEAR AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION AND
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION GROUP-
JUST CALLING TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. THANK YOU
MOVING ALONG WE WILL GO TO ONE
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS G. THE AIR SO
I REPRESENTS. THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION LICENSE RESEARCHERS
AS WELL AS REAY HAS AS WELL AS
RICK HAS WAS INTEGRATED BY OUR-
LEGISLATIVE LIAISON JOINT
COLLINS EARLIER WE ARE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. MY FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR VICE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND THEN YOU READ OR
HEAR ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
PROPERTY CASUALTY INSURANCE THAT
THE ASIAN ASKING YOU TO SUPPORT
AB TWO NINE FOUR AND WOULD LIKE
TO ALIGN OURSELVES WITH COMMENTS
FROM THE PERSONAL INSURANCE
FEDERATION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ONE FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES GREAT
THURMOND CHAIRMAN AND CHAIRMAN
BURKE- FONG- MY NAME IS YOU KNOW
AT SOME POINT FROM PLASTER
COUNTY AND I'M JUST YOU KNOW
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS THIS BILL I
FEEL LIKE- YOU MIGHT NEED A
LITTLE BIT OF- MAYBE THE
PARTIALLY GUIDED AND MAYBE RE
LOOKED AT- I AM. I AM FOR FAVOR
OF REGULATING- CHARGES FOR THE
CONSUMER I DO AGREE WITH THAT.
HOWEVER THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER-
HEY HE PART OF A VERY VALID
POINT ABOUT- THE REGULATORY FEES
. I'M BEING A LITTLE I THINK-
DEFINITELY SHOULD BE LOOKED AT
VERY LONG RANGE SO- I WOULD TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL IS IF IT. IS A
LANGUAGE HAVE BEEN CHANGED OR OR
RE LOOKED AT RETIREMENT. YOUR
TIME AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. WELCOME. I MISS
ROBERT ANY OTHER INDIVIDUALS ON
THE PHONE LINE. NOBODY ELSE IS
QUEUED UP THEM ONE ZERO AGAIN IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. MISTER CHAIR NOBODY ELSE'S
QUEUING UP. I THINK THIS
OPERATOR WE WILL NOW TAKE IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE I BELIEVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NAZARIAN HAS A
QUESTION. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- AND THANK YOU MR SANTIAGO
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
I'VE- OF. I MYSELF HAVE WANTED
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE. OUT OF
CONCERNS I'VE HEARD FROM MANY
CONSTITUENTS ESPECIALLY IN THE
LOS ANGELES AREA- FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE A AGENCIES
AND LOS ANGELES TO THE POLICE
DEPARTMENTS THAT- CONTRACT WITH-
TOW TRUCKS TO TOW TRUCK SERVICE
PROVIDING COMPANIES AND THEN YOU
HAVE THE PRIVATE SECTOR FOLKS
THAT CAN. CONTRACT WITH WHOEVER
ELSE THEY WANT AND THEN THERE'S
DIRT THERE MIGHT BE OTHER
CATEGORIES BUT THERE'S ALSO BEEN
KIND OF THE MORE. IT TO CALL IT
THIS WAY BUT LOOK FOR LACK OF A
BETTER TERM KIND OF THE RENEGADE
GROUP OF FOLKS THAT. MAY BE TOW
TRUCKS ON HIGHER- IT AND SO FROM
WHAT I UNDERSTAND THIS BRINGS
THAT THIRD GROUP OF COMPANIES.
MORE INTO- MOVEMENT BRINGS THEM
INTO A SPOTLIGHT TO ENSURE THAT
THERE IS A PROCESS AND THERE'S
QUESTION AND THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR RECOURSE IF THE
SHOULD GO ON TO CHARGE
EXORBITANT AMOUNTS AND SO I I'M
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS BILL- BUT
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
OTHER COMMENTS THAT YOU'D LIKE
TO. SHARE FROM. MISTAKEN IN MY
UNDERSTANDING NOT I THINK YOU
YOU HIT ON THE NAIL THIS IS PART
OF THIS IS WHY THE CALIFORNIA
TOW TRUCK ASSOCIATION- IS
WORKING WITH US ON THIS BILL TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS- THERE'S
FAIRNESS. FOR CONSUMERS THAT
THERE IS RECOURSE- WHERE THERE
ARE SOME- TOE WHICH FEES THAT
COULD EXCEED THOUSANDS PREDICT
AND WE HEARD VERY EARLY IN IN
THE FIRST WITNESS SPEAK ABOUT
THE CHP TOWING STORAGES. ARE
ABOUT I HOPE I GET THE NUMBER
RIGHT FOR MEMORY RIGHT NOW BUT
ABOUT NINETY THREE. DOLLARS PER
DAY SO THERE'S A DISCREPANCY NOT
NOT THOUSAND ISN'T THE AVERAGE
FOR SURE- BUT IT'S ONE EXAMPLE
OF- EXCEEDINGLY HIGH COST- WE
ALSO HEARD EXAMPLES OF ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED. NINETY PER DAY BUT BUT
THIS BILL TRIES TO DO IS SAY-
LET'S SET A STANDARD BUT THERE'S
ALSO A PLACE. WHERE CONSUMERS
CAN GO TO A- IF THIS BILL SHE
GETS SIGN. WHERE IF THERE ARE
THOSE- HI COSTS STORAGE AND THEY
MAY BE AT HAND WHERE THEY CAN
GO. AND FIND RESOLUTION OF IT
THE BOARD MAY DECIDE SO THE
COMMISSION WE DECIDE- THE
CUSTOMER'S NOT RIGHT BUT THEY
MAY DECIDE THAT THEY ARE RIGHT
IN. YOU COULD YOU HAVE A PLACE
TO DISPUTE- IN FIND ACTION IS
ACTION IS NECESSARY. COME FROM
THE APPRECIATED THANK YOU. OUR
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO A MEMBER
O'DONNELL. YES SIR THANK YOU
MUST CHAIR I JUST WANT TO WEIGH
IN ON THIS ISSUE- I THINK I'M
GOING TO BE VOTING FOR THIS BUT
I'M VERY CAUTIOUS ABOUT THIS
BILL VERY CAUTIOUS. I DROVE A
TOW TRUCK FOR FIVE YEARS AND I
THINK WHAT PEOPLE DON'T
UNDERSTAND. IS IT COSTS A LOT OF
MONEY TO OPERATE A TOW TRUCK IT
COSTS A LOT OF MONEY TO STORE
VEHICLES. K. THREE VEHICLES
PROBABLY MAKE UP A SMALL IN A
STUDIO APARTMENT. THINK WHAT
THAT'S GONNA COST JUST YOU KNOW
THE SIZE OF THAT THE SPACE OF
THAT VERSUS A THE SPACE OF YOUR
STORY THREE VEHICLES TAKES A LOT
OF MONEY IT CAN'T BE FREE OR WE
WILL NOT HAVE TOW TRUCKS ON THE
ROAD. SOME PEOPLE WANT TO MAKE
IT FREE OKAY SO MY FEAR IS THAT
WE MAY BE STACKED THE BOARD WITH
FOLKS WHO WANT TO MAKE IT FREE
AND WE END UP NO TOW TRUCKS WE
END UP WITH NO SERVICE ON THE
ROAD. PEOPLE LINE UP IN A BAD
SPOT SO I'M A LITTLE CONCERNED
ABOUT WHERE THIS IS GOING I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT IT TODAY. BUT
AGAIN I CANNOT UNDERSCORE ENOUGH
THE FACT THAT TOWING OF VEHICLES
EXPENSIVE A LIGHT DUTY TOW TRUCK
TODAY IS ABOUT A HUNDRED TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS RIGHT FOR ONE.
DAY THE INSURANCE ON THAT IS
ABOUT TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
THEN YOU HAVE WORKMAN'S COMP. ON
TOP OF THAT- VEHICLE INSURANCE
ON TOP OF THAT EMPLOYEE COSTS ON
TOP OF THAT FUEL TIRES
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT GOES ALONG
WITH OPERATING A VEHICLE OF THAT
SORT AND IT TAKES MONEY. IT
pSURE THAT. AS WE MOVE FOR THE
REPRESENTATION ON THIS BOARD IS
WISE AND THOUGHTFUL TO SMALL
BUSINESS. AND THE FACT THAT WE
ALSO NEED TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
TOW TRUCKS AND VEHICLE STORAGE
OUT THERE. AGAIN AND AGAIN.
TODOROKI EXPENSIVE STORING
VEHICLES AS EXPENSIVE AS WELL
BECAUSE YOU AGAIN YOU HAVE TO
HAVE EMPLOYEES THAT KIND OF
ACCESS TO THE VEHICLE TWENTY
FOUR HOUR SHOULD SOMEONE CALL
TWO IN THE MORNING WANNA GET
THAT VEHICLE THEY HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO GET THAT VEHICLE THERE'S
INSURANCE ASSOCIATED STORY THAT
VEHICLE WELL. THEIR SECURITY
ASSOCIATES DURING THAT. SO IT'S
NOT CHEAP ON EITHER FRONT. TO
OPERATE UNTIL TRUCK OR TO SEE-
VEHICLES I JUST HOPE PEOPLE
REALLY KEEP THAT IN MIND. AND IF
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THAT SERVICE
AVAILABLE WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S NOT GIVING AWAY.
WITHOUT IT I CAN VACUUM
STRUCTURE. I THANK YOU MISTER
O'DONNELL- WE WILL NOW MOVE THIS
NUMBER MEDINA. THANK YOU- THANK
YOU TO THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THE BILL FORWARD- IT'S AN ISSUE
THAT I THINK MANY OF US HAVE
DEALT WITH I THINK AS A YOUNG
COLLEGE STUDENT- I HAD THAT SAME
EXPERIENCE OF HAVING MY CAR
BREAK DOWN IN. YOU KNOW WASN'T
WORTH A WHOLE LOT OF MONEY. AND
SO WHEN I GOT THE BILL FOR
STORAGE YOU KNOW I SAID THANK
YOU. YOU KNOW YOU COULD KEEP
FIVE VW WAS WORTH THAT MUCH. SO
WE UNDERSTAND THE ISSUE. BUT I
HAVE TWO QUESTIONS THAT I THINK
ARE CONCERNS. OF LOCAL- TOW
TRUCK- OWNERS. AND THE FIRST ONE
IS. AND THE RELATED I BELIEVE
THE FIRST ONE IS YOU KNOW DOES
THE BILL HAVE ENOUGH TEETH IN
THE ENFORCEMENT HE SAID FOR
THOSE COMPANIES WHO CONTINUE TO
VIOLATE. THERE IS A MECHANISM
FOR CONSUMERS TO- ADDRESSES. BUT
THE CONCERN THAT I HEARD BACK
HOME WAS- WILL BE ENFORCED HOW
WILL IT BE ENFORCED DOES IT HAVE
ENOUGH T. AND THE SECOND
CONCERN. THAT I HEARD BACK HOME
IN RIVERSIDE WAS- WILL THESE
RESULT IN MORE FEES TO SMALL TOW
TRUCK OPERATORS EMPLOYEE COULD
ADDRESS IT YEAH I KNOW THE ON
THE SECOND ALL STAR BACK IN
TERMS OF THIS. THE WAY WE LOOK
AT IT WITH A TRY TO CREATE A
BALANCED APPROACH TO IT WHICH IS
WHY WE PARTNERED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TOW TRUCK ASSOCIATION
TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THAT
FAIR BALANCE IT SO THEY'RE IN
THE ROOM AND THEY'RE WORKING
WITH US- IN TERMS OF THE
COMMISSION. SORRY THE BOARD TO
KEEP CALL COMMISSION AT THE IN
THE BOARD WOULD HAVE IN IT TO
BALANCED- LAW ENFORCEMENT- THE
TOWING INDUSTRY INSURANCE AUTO
REPAIR- AND THEN TO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC SO THAT THE- TOTAL
SEVEN PEOPLE WHO WOULD BALANCE
IT OUT. AS IT WAS FOR WHAT WHAT
IT WHAT IT GIVES THE OPPORTUNITY
IS TO BE ABLE TO DISPUTE BEFORE
THE BOARD AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
THIS PARTICULAR CHARGE- WAS-
OUTSIDE THE ORDINARY CHARGE OR
JUST TOO HIGH LIKE IN THE CASE
OF. MAYOR MAY NOT HAPPEN WITH
YOU RIGHT SO IF THE BOARD WOULD
THEN HAVE THE ABILITY TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THIS COST AND SAY WELL
YEAH MAYBE THOUSAND DOLLARS WAS
TOO HIGH- FOR THOSE FIVE DAYS
EQUALING FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
SIDE IN THE CASE THAT. TOO HIGH.
SO ABILITY TO GO BEFORE AND
THIS. MOUNTAIN TO THE PEOPLE
THIS IS A WORK IN PROGRESS RIGHT
SO WE COULD STILL GO BACK. TO
WE'VE GOT THE WHOLE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS TO TAKE A LOOK AT
WHETHER IT IS. IT IS STRONG
ENOUGH- CURRENTLY WE TOOK. WE
TOOK THE TO MEET THE COMMITTEES
AT THE COMMITTEE'S APPROACH- IN
TERMS OF. IN TERMS OF TAKE A
LOOK AT THIS AND MOVING FOR BUT-
I'M OPEN TO TAKING A LOOK AT IT
TO SEE IF THEY HAD MORE PEOPLE.
WHAT IS REAL IN HERE TO DO WAS
TO CREATE. A PLACE. WHERE A
YOUNG MISTER MEDINA COULD HAVE
GONE AND SAID LOOK THIS IS TOO
HIGH. AND THAT THAT BOARD WAS
SAID. YOU'RE RIGHT OR YOU'RE
WRONG- IN THAT PARTICULAR CASE-
MAYBE. IN OTHER SITUATIONS WHERE
THAT WOULD HAPPEN MEET MAYBE YOU
WOULD HAVE TO GIVE UP THE CAR- I
ONLY USE THAT EXAMPLE. YEP THERE
ARE SOME EXAMPLES THAT ARE
EXTREMELY HIGH. AND ARE THERE
SOME THAT MAYBE FARE- THAT MAYBE
FAIR TO ADDRESS. THE QUESTION
FROM THE PART PREVIOUS COLLEGE-
THAT'S WHY WE SET UP IN THAT
PARTICULAR. AND THAT'S WHY WE
ARE WORKING- WITH THE INDUSTRY
AS TO WHAT THAT FAIR NUMBER
MIGHT BE. AND THEN THE SECOND
QUESTION THIS. IS YOUR SANTIAGO
IS- ABOUT THE FEES WITH WITH
WITH LOCAL OPERATORS SEE. OF
THEIR FEES GO UP- WELL I DON'T
KNOW WE'LL SEE THEIR FEES WELL
LOOK- HAPPY TO DIG INTO THAT A
LITTLE BIT MORE BUT THE WAY WE
TOOK A LOOK AT IT WAS- MORE ON
THE COST OF THE INDIVIDUAL SO IF
. I HAD MY CAR TOWED- IN DISPUTE
WOULD BE- WHAT THAT COST. OF A
STORAGE PER DAY WOULD BE. THAT'S
WHAT'S REALLY IN DISPUTE. ABOUT
BUT HAVE YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
WEATHER THAT DOESN'T DOESN'T I
DID. I HAPPEN TO SIT ON BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS WHO I THINK IS
GOING TO HEAR THIS BILL TOMORROW
I BELIEVE- WE ARE WE ARE BUT
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT WHICH LATER
THIS WEEK SO- I'M GONNA STAY OFF
TODAY AND SEE IF WE CAN. I CAN
FIND MORE ANSWERS FOR WHICH IT I
THINK. IS THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE. A
SEEN AS AND AS MENTIONED BEFORE
THIS BILL DOES- MOVE FORWARD TO
THE NEXT COMMITTEE WHICH IS
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND- AND-
THE I KNOW THERE WILL BE- AND
INTENSE REVIEW- FROM THAT
COMMITTEE AS WELL AS SOMEBODY
DOES SERVE A BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AS WELL- SEEING NO
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS I INVITE THE AUTHOR TO
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
CAN APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
INPUT. AND WILLINGNESS TO WORK
WITH THANK. I THINK YOU- WE HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND- AGAIN
THIS BILL- PROCEEDS TO THE
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE
NEXT SO- AMOUNTS AFTER A PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AB TWO NINETY
FOUR DO PASSED TO BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE. FONG HI
FONG I BERMAN. BERMAN I
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I DAILY
DAILY AYE DAVIES DAVIES I GIPSON
. KALRA KALRA HI LEE LI I MEDINA
. MEDINA NOT VOTING. IN THIS
AREA AND I WENT. WHEN NOT VOTING
O'DONNELL HERE WARD HI I WARD I
WICKS HI WICKS HI. FIVE RIGHT
KERN VOTE TEN ZERO OKAY WILL
KEEP THE- ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS FOR THEM TO ADD ON I
THINK IT IS A MEDINA. WE HAVE.
OKAY WE HAVE TWO ITEMS ON
CONSENT- THE MOTION. SECOND AB
THE ONE ZERO FOUR FIVE ELEVEN
ACR SEVENTY FOUR SALAS- EXACTLY
PLEASE CALDERON CONSENT FILE CAN
ITEMS ON CONSENT FONG HI FONG I
BERMAN BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. DALY AYE AYE DALY
AYE DAVIES AYE DAVIES AYE GIPSON
. KALRA KALRA I THREE FIVE THREE
I NOT MEDINA I AM VERY IN FIVE
THIS AREA I WENT WHEN I
O'DONNELL. LORD LORD I WICKS
WICKS HI. GIPSON FIVE GIPSON AYE
THINK YOU. THE NUMBER WAITING
FOR. BOTH WOOD MISTER ABOUT YEAH. JUST LISTEN TO THEM THAT THE
IS A- ELEVEN I WANT TO ELEVEN
ZERO YEP ALL RIGHT WE WILL KEEP
THAT WILL KEEP THE ROLE FOR
ABSENT. SYSTEM TO OFFER. WELL WE
HAVE- MISTER GIBSON HERE'S A
WILL REOPEN- AB TWO NINE FOUR
FILE ITEM THREE EIGHTY TO NINETY
FOUR GIPSON GIPSON I CURRENT
VOTE THE LEVIN CARE OF. THIS
ELEVEN ZERO WE'LL KEEP THE ROAD
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
TRANSMONTAIGNE. THE. NINETY SO
OFTEN. YEAH YEAH YEAH YEAH OKAY
SO WE HAVE. OKAY. YEAH YEAH.
OKAY THERE ARE MANY THINGS THAT
. AND AUGUST. YEAH NINE AND
WE'LL TALK MORE SO. YEAH. YEAH
MAKE SURE THEY'RE ALL. NO ORANGE
OF THIS.
WITH THE. THAT'S RIGHT
- BECAUSE. OKAY.
YEAH. AS OKAY.
WHAT YOU SEE ON. YEAH. THAT THAT
. BUT IT. RIGHT. FOR THOSE.
RIGHT THAT THAT PREVENTION RIGHT
. I MEAN. LISTEN HOUSE ABOUT.
RIGHT YEAH THAT- OKAY YEAH. YEAH
BECAUSE OF OUR INFORMATION. THE
CARD DOWN YEAH. YEAH YEAH. LIKE
IF I BREAK DOWN. YEAH. YEAH.
WHATEVER. DISTORTION. THE. THAT
WOULD BE IT WOULD BE ON TOP OF.
K. E. Y. THAT IS WHAT IS A SORT
THAT CAN COUNTY IS. YES THEY.
YEAH. YEAH YEAH THAT MAYBE. SO
UPDATED YEAH. YEAH ALONG THEY
WERE YEAH.
YEAH. YEAH. UHHUH
THANK YOU- IF YOU THINK THE. BAY
CITY VIA. I MEAN THAT THAT THE
MOTHERS AND REYES. EIGHT BUT THE
OTHER. YEAH EVERY STORY. RIGHT
NOW. IN THIS ORDER. OKAY. EIGHTY
SIX. WHAT YOU DO RIGHT. THE
FORCE. NEVER THEY WERE LIKE. IT
IS. ALL RIGHT. WILL REOPEN THE
ROLE FOR A S. S. MEMBERS TO
VOTE- IN AB TODAY FOR. FILE ITEM
THREE AB TWO NINETY FOUR
O'DONNELL HI I DON'T KNOW I-
TWELVE ZERO FIVE ABOUT TWELVE
ZERO THE GETS OUT- AND THEN ON
CONSENT ITEMS AB TWO TO TEN
FORTY FIVE IN A C. R. THIRTY
FOUR IS ON CONSENT O'DONNELL I.
ALSO DON'T HI. THAT GETS OUT- I
THINK WE ARE WE ARE DONE AND WE
WILL ADJOURN THIS HEARING-
THAT'S A BUSINESS OVER THE
SUMMER JUST BECAUSE HAS
BASICALLY IS NOT COMPLETE.
NUMBER THANK YOU.